viens je t'ai fait un p'tit déj
spéciales et marie ouvre la porte
tu es ravissant
je me sens bien que ces princesses
disney
[Musique]
on courait les special one tu as dit que
tu m'avais fait un petit déjeuner
spécial
[Musique]
on oblige pas y aller tu peux continuer
à me donner des cours j'ai enseigné tout
ce que je sais mais je veux pas y aller
c'est tout moi je veux pas aller au
travail mais j'y vais turgot travail
tueur et par des bateaux sur un pied
ouais c'est un mauvais exemple
n'empêche que tirant wilfred alors moi
fred tu vas pas t'occuper de lui tu
aimes pas les charges aime pas les chats
deux yeux et fred tu le sais monoculaire
et qui va lui lancé sa balle de ping
pong survivra sujet est clos d'accord on
en a discuté à nauseam ces points à 2/12
tu sais pas j'en connais une qui doit
aller à l'école
oblige pas y aller
des cours jeudi enseigner tout ce que je
sais le sujet est clos d'accord on en a
discuté à nauseam
c'est moi a dit nous y sommes tu sais
pas j'en connais une qui doit aller à
l'école
[Musique]
chantal majestueuse hall qui peut me
dire combien font au plus 3 remet tout
le monde sait que ça fait 6 marie tu
veux bien te lever sort et tu me dire
combien font disons 135 x 57
très bien cet 1695 la racine carrée et
87,7 et des poussières
sinon ça veut dire quoi à 12 jan lauwe
tout je pense que votre guerre et
surdoué diane voulait que marie soit
comme les autres quelle est sa vie
normale une enfance une dame qui attend
devant notre porte
cette dame est à grand mère c'est un
macbook chéri qu'est ce que tu fais ici
m'a rien normale peut enrichir sa vie ce
manque est le signe - devant l'exposant
partie pourquoi nos surya qui
s'affrontent dit que je dois corriger
les grandes personnes
les gens n'aiment pas les jeux c'est
tout arrive
[Musique]
je langage d'exploiter ce potentiel
quelle est ta plus grande peur c'est de
gâcher la vie paris
[Musique]
c'est pas grave